30 years
since the birth of the world wide web
i believe it so that would
if it
reassure me that we are now in 2021
so therefore we must be talking about
1991. that was a weird era i mean in my
pronouncement so far i think we've got
to the stage
of
the mid-80s where you had macintoshes
becoming available you had uh other
workstations beginning to become
available from people like sun and
apollo domain i think it was something
like that so things were moving on
but yet
weirdly
the world wide web
which came after the internet remember
is basically how should these internet
capabilities be harnessed and packaged
to be
shown and cameraman friendly so the
ordinary mortals can
do it you know and it was not obvious
in those early days i seem to recall
there were information services when
they're like archie waze wide area
information systems
people were really trying to find out
well if we do have interconnected
networks on computers how do you know
who's got what and where everything is
and i think the idea about ways was
making
basically catalogues of what's where and
all this kind of thing but i think to be
fair to him berners-lee's great
achievement was being able to think out
of the box perhaps it was the fact that
he was trained as a scientist and not as
a computer scientist and i don't know
that he could think outside the box but
basically the whole
thing about you know the
http
and the internet protocol and all this
kind of stuff
really he managed to work out pretty
something pretty robust about how this
would work in the very early days i
think we touched before you know in the
fact that the gap between something
becoming
vaguely possible
and something becoming commonplace could
be anything up to 10 years did we once
agree and here's a classic example of it
i mean
in 1991 yes i was very slightly aware of
it but i didn't see it going to the
internet such as it wasn't any
development so i didn't see it as being
massively essential well of course we
didn't actually have the internet so the
news wasn't traveling
you had to read about it somewhere yeah
in a print um
or some kind of mail shop yes
that's right in fact my very earliest
usages of the web when it became
available were for really boring things
like
working out that so-and-so had got a set
of files that implemented something on
another unix machine so wow we didn't
necessarily have to make a magnetic tape
or burn a cd or whatever we could
actually
go to that site not just to pick up a
bit of email because that was fairly
straightforward but also to actually
with permission
download a whole suite of files what
about photos then my memory about early
attempts to download
photos
down an early web thing i mean honestly
but my memory is of being at university
and a friend of mine going on bbs's
bulletin board systems yes and this was
after the worldwide web existed
but we had some sort of fractured
connection to the web through a bbs yes
and yeah occasionally you might be sent
some photos and it took an age to
download them and by the time they
downloaded were they what you wanted in
the first place possibly not yeah do you
go off and spend another several minutes
waiting for the next one to download yes
i think this is where we would benefit
if people wanted to say more on this
from having got julian onions as part of
the uh
computer file team as it were because he
was
he was with me i think as i remember in
that first phase of his career at
nottingham i think he was with me till
the early 90s and
he would be pretty sound on which
machine was it that first had a web
browser on it capable of even visiting
another site let alone doing anything
serious the ability to actually
have
what should we say
interactive video material made
available at ultra slow speeds over the
web
may have been in the early to mid 90s
among the ultra keen people who could
just about bear getting it to work but
how long does it take to become
commonplace the answer as ever is 10
years my major concern at the time
late 80s early 90s exactly this era
for me
was a transition from postscript to pdf
now we've done
videos
on certain aspects of this
but i think perhaps what i haven't
explained about my great adventures in
this regard
was that in the middle 1980s and with
the development and announcement of
postscript basically as a
graphics language available on
macintosh's and
notoriously
available by having
a laser printer running that language
requiring enormous amounts of memory for
the time costing a fortune it couldn't
be got any cheaper than seven thousand
dollars but it was touch and go i mean
the hardware was only just fast enough
to render that page at that time what
struck me at the time and i was very
much in the era of knowing that my
future in some sense would lie in
documents digital documents electronic
publishing
i thought you know
there is something about this language
because of course postscript is turing
complete it's a weird language remember
it works on a stack you overtly program
in reverse polish you don't say
a plus b or even plus a b you say a b
plus and in a much more verbose way that
is the way
postgrit works on top of it being an
excellent 2d graphics language moving
beyond what
most printers would have regarded as the
toy
of the
laser printer people began to ask would
it be possible to put this postscript
language on real typesetters yes it
would
and
a bit bemused i think
by the runaway success of the apple
laserwriter
yes it was um a liner type that took the
initiative
of saying yes to
an idea internally about how do we try
and migrate postscript onto a real
typesetter because i've talked about my
adventures with the 202 type center but
it was not post group based but they
tried one out just as an idea and people
said oh that's wonderful we want it
don't matter about the cost too much but
you'll have to get it down quite a lot
from that if you want to sell lots and
lots of them
so in the end then that convinced me
that just in my narrow world of journal
publication i wanted to create an
electronic document
uh
learned journal which i did
didn't run for very long because the
electronic documents learned conference
was far more popular than the journal so
we started off with electronic
publishing but then gradually it morphed
into being a vehicle for publishing the
proceedings of the document engineering
symposium as it were and it's gone to
great guns from there but anyway um i
was messing about then at an early stage
with doing proceedings for conferences
all in postscript and thinking well
this is good because you're actually
archiving a program and
this could run
you know although the hardware will be
very different and maybe they're
emulating a layer on top of it there
will always be a way you can write an
interpreter for postscript so here's my
electronic archive that is potentially
machine independent yes of course
printers archived but they always
archived on the basis that the world
would be
ruled totally
by
you know monotype and liner type and
they are in charge and what they say
goes and i was treated like a pariah for
saying i'm sorry it's not going to be
like that
it's all about computer graphics and
it's computing companies that are going
to win out of this not just purely
graphic type set of companies and i was
right but nobody would listen to me at
the time so yes um
this is
perhaps another anecdote of how i met
john warnock because people ask me and
say well how did adobe get to know about
your conviction that uh postscript would
be a good archiving mechanism
and the answer was that i was working
with john wiley uk the publishers
journal publishers at the time and
suddenly my contact at wiley's down on
the south coast got a dear mark behind
that was a name we understand
from our contacts that you are
considering doing a future journal
related to electronic publishing and
that it might be under consideration as
to whether to use postscript as the
typesetting language and as the archival
names would you care to join me and my
colleague dr chuck geshke for tea in
london
at the park lane hotel i think it was
signed your sincerely john warnock the
two co-founders of adobe so mark rang me
up in great excitement said well you
know this madcap idea of yours of using
the most expensive type setting software
solution seems to at least have got the
big boys interested and yes it was
absolutely hilarious i mean
john wasn't is a good friend
as a result of this largely because it
was clear he and chuck were such good
friends and so much singing from the
same hymn sheet
there was nothing put on about it they
just said we're delighted you're doing
this and we'll give you every help
obviously you know i think at the end of
the talk they did indicate that there
were works in progress that might come
up with a
sort of version of postscript that was
much more suited
to doing electronic documents
um
i think the feeling was well
postscript's wonderful
but it is turing completion in a sense
it's too powerful there is nothing in
postscript to say
here is my code for rendering this page
it will be beautiful but tell you what
just to annoy you all
before i do this i'm going to use
postscript to calculate ackermann 4-2
which was we all know takes 27
quadrillion years or even a command
3-mark 1 which might take 15 minutes
of course you wouldn't do that
but somebody malevolent might do that to
you
so in a sense postscript being turing
complete was perhaps a bit too powerful
for something that only needed a
declarative statement of i want this to
happen exactly this i will leave the
implementation of it to you
now in a way
it rang bells when the web became
available because here
was yet another declarative solution but
coming from a slightly different
direction
so this adobe thing which was eventually
revealed to me as pdf
and the other declarative solution
which was not as how should we say
dot for dot accurate at the time as per
script i saw them very much as being
complementary you know if you want to
ultra super
vogue fashion magazines electronically
over the web yes it's going to be pdf if
you just want some pretty decent
graphics although it's developed a lot
worldwide web but using a declarative
model of the html language where
i think as we've discussed the
difference between an imperative
language that can do ackerman's function
and a declarative one that can't is that
one can this during complete that can do
anything needs to be able to ask for
more memory and get it
there is no way in pdf for overtly
asking and saying give me lots of memory
because i want to mess about and make
you unbelievably slow
and
that's a great advantage to have a
restricted language that will try and
stop people playing games if you could
have hidden things in pdf
would it have would it have yeah would
it have taken off i don't think it would
and i think i i remember hearing that
there'd been a robust discussion at
adobe to the effect that one or two
people were starting to use
postscript kind of preludes to do all
sorts of weird and hairy things and
wasn't this a fantastic selling point
for pdf as a rapper format for anything
and everything and uh
the answer came back from somebody on
the team there
saying basically this is not a feature
it is a bug and we have got to sit on it
firmly people are now of course utterly
aware of trojans and so on and so forth
in a way that they weren't in the
uh kind of early late 80s early 90s when
this was just seen as oh wow isn't this
incredible so that was the situation
then you'd got like a a bit of a chasm
between the two
between html
and pdf one of the things that
fortunately happened around about the
early 90s
was that
tim berners-lee and others headed off at
the pass any attempt
to
make
as it were the web be of property of
either apple or microsoft or whoever he
set up the world wide web consortium
who's you know
one of his founding tenants was to try
and be platform neutral fair to
everybody and to have clearly published
standards the worldwide web consortium
that everybody could agree to and nobody
would try and pull a fast one on anybody
else
because i think
even microsoft had to admit they'd try
and rule the world with it but they
wouldn't succeed but latterly of course
what has changed everything
and
again this business about
just faintly possible to send a
photograph or a slow moving movie in the
early to mid 90s everything totally
routine and above board youtube 2004-5
something like that
what was needed of course in those 10
years was not just any further
realization about the language it was
just the infrastructure needed to be
faster
so there of course you're up against
telcos and telecom companies have to be
sufficiently enough of computer
companies or have big clients saying we
need more bandwidth we do not want 38
kilobits per second out of apple talk
thank you very much we would like it to
be at least 38 megabits right factor of
a thousand faster now get on with it but
of course once it's been established
that serious people with serious money
will pay for that
then development will follow but there
is always a bit of a a lag a bit of a
induction period there for people say
yeah you know that idiot brush is right
this is going to take off we better make
plans
rpc protocols and network stacks and so
on and just quickly bolted on a thing
that let it be accessed as a
probably a gift actually size of it and
the
operator this is called select font so
it binds this point size to this font
and says right that's what we use